who I'm gonna start teddy I'm gonna
start teddy big after I start Aaron and
bread
I'm Greg Jennings and this is start
bench cut oh so I'm gonna start
basketball and the reason why basketball
is my first love a lot of people don't
know this I got recruited more for
basketball than I ever did in football I
was dead - how was the problem period
I'm gonna bench golf only reason why I'm
benching golf is because I play golf now
I became a golfer about four years ago
I'm absolutely just consumed with golf
so I will put it above basketball but
basketball is just you get the round
ball in my hand I just gotta talk and
then i'ma cut football and the reason
why I've done that man watch out watch
out okay i'ma start Criminal Minds
Criminal Minds that was my introduction
baby that was my cameo that was my he
killed all those women then he killed
himself kind of a public service all
right then I'm gonna [ __ ] Royal Pains
and then the league imma cut the league
because again it's the league I've lived
that life I've done that get up out of
here I'm gonna start Eddie I'm gonna
start Eddie big after I start errands
and bread so with that said I must start
Aaron wait a minute and my plan okay
let's start this over so now if I'm
playing in the game I'm gonna start
brett farr and here's why really quick
because brett gives me the opportunity
and the Liberty and the freedom to do
what I do which is go get that ball make
a play G who can make a place I can okay
that's what Brett affords Erin I'm going
to bench him I mean we know who he is
he's Aaron Rodgers he's mr. perfection
he doesn't really necessarily need me to
be me because he's gonna eliminate all
playmaking
opportunity because he's so perfect
which is not a knock is just why I would
prefer to start Brett and then Teddy B
I'm gonna cut you man because our our
stint with one another it was a little
bittersweet man I needed you to step up
even more no I might still be playing
today but you didn't so go for that I'm
right here
and you still playing so numb but I am
gonna cut you it's Brett in his hand I
mean you will cut you
I'm Greg Jennings and this is start big
cut